- "How does the heart keep
beating and beating for years
and never stop?"
Don't stop, won't stop,
heartbeats for life.
It just does.
You have an SA node, an AV
node, the Purkinje fibers,
they go throughout your heart
and they help your conduction.
If the electrical system is there,
the musculoskeletal system will listen.
As long as everything else is in place
you know, oxygen, electrolytes,
all the good stuff.
"Okay, so pathologists study
a tumor once it's removed,
but then what?
Does it get incinerated?
Sent to the dump? Shot into space?"
Well, it doesn't get shot into space,
'cause that'd be quite expensive.
It gets thrown out in
the biohazard disposal.
What happens with it then?
I have no idea.
But you've seen those biohazard red bins,
that's where the tumor goes.
And there's no need to incinerate it,
you don't need to burn it.
Actually, I guess if there's like
infectious things in there,
maybe you do need to burn it,
and it ends up being incinerated.
Like let's Google what happens.
"What happens to biohazard waste?"
Oh, 90% of biohazard waste is incinerated.
The more you know.
"An onlooker has the
choice to save five people
being in danger of being hit by a trolley,
by diverting the trolley
to just kill one person.
We know Dr. Mike would pull that lever,
because he has no problem
murdering someone for charity."
#creatorclash, what is that?
I don't get it.
Oh, because I murdered
iDubbbz for charity?
I didn't murder him, he's doing great.
Would you divert the trolley
to just kill one person?
Oh man.
There's too many other factors
that I don't have the information to.
And as a doctor who thrives
in the sea of nuance,
I refuse to swim in this ocean.
- [Observer] Ooh, good answer.
That's professional.
(Dr. Mike laughs)
Well done.
- "Is it bad to draw
on my hand with a pen?
My mom tells me it will
give me pen cancer."
Never heard of pen cancer.
Heard of pen15 cancer
if you know what I mean.
"Do nipples grow back?"
Do they grow back after what?
Is my question.
If you had a traumatic thing
where you lost a nipple,
no, just skin would form there.
123Music, "If I scratch my mosquito bite,
will it get itchier?"
Absolutely.
The reason this happens is
because of histamine production,
the more you scratch,
the more inflammation,
the more histamine, the bigger the hive,
the more itchy it becomes.
And if you cause excoriations,
which means openings in the skin,
you could actually create
an infection on top of it,
which is a problem,
'cause now you're gonna
have to put steroidal cream
to decrease the itching,
and then an antibiotic cream
to fight the infection.
"Is it true that if you
chew gum while studying,
then chew the same flavor
gum while taking the test,
you'll recall the information
you studied better?"
It's possible.
They say that you should try and replicate
your study environment as much as you can
during your testing environment.
I think that probably goes a step too far.
You're probably spending more effort
in trying to do this
kind of hacking thing,
than actually the effort
that you could be spending on studying.
If you love chewing gum and
you love the minty flavors,
stick with the minty flavor, don't change.
And know that if you cram
and you stay up all night,
it won't enter your long term memory,
the information you studied.
"Is it weird to go to a
doctor for multiple things
at the same time?
What should I do if I have
several things to go over
and only few minutes?"
Great question.
Can we cover multiple issues in one visit?
Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
If your symptoms are connected,
and can be pointing to
one universal problem
that's causing all of these symptoms.
If you have diarrhea,
are sweating profusely,
are having palpitations,
perhaps you're having a thyroid issue.
And had you only presented
one of those concerns to me,
I might miss the thyroid issue,
'cause I think, "Oh, diarrhea,
maybe just an upset stomach
related to something you ate."
Why sometimes no?
Well, if you come in and
you say your foot hurts
because you sprained your ankle,
but then you also get headaches sometimes,
and then you're also
due for your pap smear.
You could see how we can't get
all that done in one visit,
but a good doctor will say
what's the most important to you,
and what they think the most important
is to address in a given moment,
meaning what's the most timely,
and then we can reschedule
you for a follow up visit.
"Does it matter when during the day
humans get eight hours of sleep?
I have friends who are bartenders at night
and then sleep during the day."
If you're getting seven
to nine hours of sleep,
that's important,
but then consistency is also important,
and then also the time of day
of sleep is also important.
Humans are not nocturnal creatures,
so we need to be out in the sun,
and that's how our circadian rhythms work.
People who work during the
night and sleep during the day
have more health problems on average.
And we don't have the exact
reason as to why that happens,
but we know that it's definitely present.
We actually even have a disorder
called shift work disorder
from individuals who have that problem.
"When I have aches and pains,
I treat it with a cocktail approach,
some acetaminophen, some
ibuprofen, some aspirin,
all at once.
Should I continue this approach,
or is one better than the other?
Is one better than the
other is actually a question
I get a lot from patients.
They're like, "I have this
ache or I have a fever."
All three of these medications
are pain and fever reducers.
There's certain instances
where I would recommend
one over the other,
one is not the best.
For example, if you have kidney problems,
you may not wanna be taking
an ibuprofen medication
which gets excreted through the kidneys
and can potentially damage the kidneys.
If on the other hand, you
have really bad liver disease,
maybe you wanna not be
taking acetaminophen,
'cause that gets metabolized
within your liver.
There's different instances
where you wanna be smart,
for example, if you're prone to bleeding
and have a bleeding disorder,
aspirin can actually
inactivate your platelets
and cause you to bleed more.
I try and minimize the
use of these medications,
because reducing fevers is
not always a good thing.
A fever is beneficial,
it's helping you overcome
whatever infection you may have,
so unless there's a reason,
we shouldn't be lowering
a fever in many cases.
"Has a patient ever come in
with a disease or a condition
you've never heard of before?"
Absolutely.
Remember I'm a family medicine doctor,
anything can walk through
my door at any time.
And I have to not only figure that out,
but also maybe even learn
about that condition
right there on the spot.
And the more open you
can be with a patient
about what you know and
what you don't know,
the better that line of
communication's gonna be,
because not everyone can know
all the answers right away.
"Why does taking a long, deep
breath help calm you down?"
Because it actually
activates your vagus nerve.
That is the primary nerve in your body
responsible for parasympathetic tone,
meaning your ability to begin
rest, repair and digestion.
If you're very riled up,
you could have decreased
activation of this vagus nerve,
and as a result, be very on edge.
So when you take that deep breath,
it actually helps normalize
the parasympathetic tone,
helps calm you down, and you chill out.
"Why do I sometimes like
the smell of my own farts?"
Okay Krissy, didn't expect
that you'd go there.
But there's actually a
psychological phenomenon
that's occurring here.
The longer your body is
exposed to a specific stimuli
from outside the body,
so for example, when
you try and go to sleep,
white noise works well,
because your body starts to
tune out the white noise,
'cause it's the same level of noise.
That's why noise that's
quiet and then really loud
will wake you up at night,
'cause it triggers your
brain to react to it.
But if you constantly
over time smell your farts
and smell your own body,
you become accustomed to it.
So it doesn't trigger that same level
of response from your brain.
So when others smell other
farts, poop or what have you,
it triggers in them that
there's a foreign substance,
potentially poisonous substance,
that they should stay away from.
But when it's your own,
your body's not having that threat,
because it's been smelling it for so long,
you have a decreased stimulus response.
"When people train to hold
more air in the lungs,
what exactly is getting stronger?
Do the lungs inflate more?"
Well yeah, the lungs can inflate more,
hormonally, things change,
cellularly, things change,
like you're able to produce
more red blood cells,
you have a higher hematocrit,
you're able to withstand
periods of anaerobic stress
for longer periods of time,
so you have better lactic
acid removal from your body.
So it's not just like hold
more air in your lungs,
it's the processing of
being in an anaerobic state
that is equally important
in this situation.
"Hey Dr. Mike, my family tells
me that eating too much salt
will melt my bones.
Is this true?
And if so, how much salt is too much?
Melt your bones?
Melt? Melt?
I don't know.
Is it ideal to eat too much salt?
No.
There's recommended dietary intake
for every age group and it's different,
it's also based on health conditions,
so I can't give you an exact number
but just don't over salt your foods.
Moderation.
"Why are some people able
to live well into the 90s
if they are heavy smokers?"
Well, this is important,
and it kind of brings up the notion
of what happens when you
have unhealthy habits.
Too often I tell patients,
"Hey, you shouldn't smoke."
And they say, "Well, my
loved one lived a long life
and didn't even have lung cancer."
But the important thing to remember
is not all smokers end
up getting lung cancer.
In fact, most smokers
don't get lung cancer.
A lot of smokers get diseases
like COPD, emphysema,
these are quality of life reducers
and quantity of life reducers.
So you may live into your 90s,
but you have to live with an oxygen tank,
and have such bad dyspnea
or shortness of breath
that you can't walk to the bathroom
without feeling a tremendous
amount of air hunger.
It's not just do you die,
it's how well you live,
and with what conditions you live.
I misdraw my life videos, so I made one.
Animated story of how I came to America.
Such a good,
"well, I bet you don't
know a lot about me."
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)